hey guys i'm lisa foiles welcome to
analog today things get a little grim
and mysterious as we celebrate Big B and
he's not so innocent storybook friends
the wolf among us the episodic series by
Telltale Games for nearly all modern
systems and PC just wrapped up its
season with an incredible final
installment but fear not adventure
gamers here are three games like the
wolf among us telltale has resurrected
and made over adventure games I would
recommend any series they offer Back to
the Future Monkey Island Sam and Max but
the best and most similar to the wolf
among us is the walking dead everyone
knows the walking dead yet from the
graphic novels or the TV show however
those mediums force you to experience
the story from the outside while the
walking dead video game lets you decide
your fate and the fate of those around
you similar to the wolf among us both
games are identical in game plan you're
a troubled man in a dangerous world in
this case you're a convict in the zone
paka lips you encounter other characters
and you communicate with them you have
limited time to choose your dialogue and
everything you say is remembered while
Big B stays busy deciding who's head to
smash in Lee must focus on how to
distract Walker's to keep he and
Clementine safe while also smashing in
an undead header to you choose your path
by the last episode in the series every
player will have different friends foes
and survivors it's extremely similar to
the wolf among us but this one is so
emotional it will make you cry unless
you're dead inside speaking of dead
inside I used to say do whatever you can
to hunt down a copy of this pc game but
luckily Tim Schafer announced the
remastered version is coming soon to ps4
and Vita it's grim fandango
the wolf among us begins as a murder
mystery Grim Fandango is also a mystery
but is less concerned with how the
victims died and more with what is
happening to them now that they're dead
yes you play as many calavera a grim
reaper in the land of the dead Grim
Fandango has a noir melodramatic feel
mixed with a dia de los muertos theme
and one sexy soundtrack but underneath
the atmosphere is a hilarious point
click adventure in a more classic style
than the wolf among us sure there are
dialogue choices to help uncover clues
but it's more focused on puzzles how
does the skeleton arm interact with a
snow machine how can I rigged a roulette
game to manipulate the attendance of my
casino on top of it all it's one of the
funniest games I've ever played come on
you're a grim reaper / travel agent on a
four-year journey with a gambling
addicted orange demon trying to find
your hot dead girlfriend I'm counting
the days Schaefer looks like some sort
of morningside plane click adventures
are native to PC they just work best
with a keyboard and mouse but the DS has
proven to be a great platform for
adventure games with one of the best
being ghost trick phantom detective
zombies Grim Reaper's how about a ghost
ghost trick is also a murder mystery
with a bit of a noir feel but the victim
this time is you you're a detective
who's been murdered so you must solve
the case as a bodyless spirit if you
didn't mind all the reading that went
along with the wolf among us then you
should be fine with ghost trick because
heads up it's very wordy it really does
feel like an old-school point-and-click
ER and light Grim Fandango is all about
the puzzles as a ghost you enchant
objects to manipulate them into
interacting with each other and
achieving goals like dropping a wrecking
ball on a bad guy you also have the
ability to rewind time four minutes to
avoid tragedies and save lives plus
telephone lines let you teleport to new
locations it's well-written has a very
interesting cast of characters and is
awesomely animated sure there are more
decision heavy serious detective games
out there like heavy rain but telltale
has taken such strides to revive
adventure games I'm sticking with that
theme plus I need more people to help me
mag Tim Schafer
that's the real reason leave a comment
with games you think are similar to the
wolf among us plus send me a tweet to at
least files I'll see you on the other
side